hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast investigating colorectal
cancer using epithelial organoid
cultures presented by dr. chi creche mar
postdoctoral researcher kubera institute
i'm alexis carlos of lab roots and i'll
be our moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by thermo Fisher Scientific
for more information on our sponsor
please visit thermo Fisher comm now
let's get started before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into that ask a
question and click on the send button
well answer as many questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
also please notice that you will be
viewing the presentation in the slide
window to enlarge the window click on
the arrows at the top right hand corner
at the slide window if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problems by clicking on the
answer question box located on the far
left of your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credits
I'd like to now introduce our presenter
dr. [ __ ] Rushmore
[ __ ] Rushmore received his PhD from the
University of Cambridge in 2014 during
his doctoral training under the
supervision of Fiona what he studied the
role of canonical WMT signalling and the
plasticity of adult murren skin and
epidermal stem cell heterogeneity
subsequently I joined the laboratory of
hands cleavers at the Hebron Institute
in your tricks to investigate the
heterogeneity of the tumor
microenvironment in colorectal cancer
dr. crush Mar you may now begin your
presentation
thank you very much for this kind
introduction and the title of my
presentation you already heard I will
talk about using if a fee of organized
cultures to investigate colorectal
cancer
I have small review provided I will
first actually introduce you to correct
the cancer give you some facts about it
and some some kind of basic biology to
this disease and then I will introduce
actually what if at the orgonite
cultures are and how we can use them to
grow normal colon if the theme as well
as colorectal cancer tissue I will
continue in the third part of my book
showing you some data that we have
published how we can actually use
organized cultures to biobank actual
cancer tissue from patients and use them
for drug screens analysis etc in the
last part of my talk I will actually
show you how we can use normal colon
organoids and genetically manipulate
these to study and model the progression
of tumors as you would see them in a
patient okay let me start with an
introduction to colorectal cancer
colorectal cancer is actually one of the
most common cancers in the world it's in
the top 5 of new cancer cases per year
but also actually in the top 5 of cancer
related deaths per year and therefore of
course are very important cancer to be
studied
classically it's been it's been believed
that colorectal cancer rises in an
economical way from normal from normal
colon if esteem which acquired mutations
that lead to the development of a small
adenoma which then progresses into a
large adenoma and then eventually in vey
aged patients it presents itself as a
proper colorectal cancer carcinoma and
study by focus team showed actually that
these these steps towards the disease
associated with mutations in very
critical genes such as a p ck Rossi 53
and smart 4 so the mutations that you
find in APC in play arouse actually
activate the pathway so they're
chronically up regulated and inactive
whereas p53 and smart four are usually
mutations that inactivate and these
oncogenes and therefore allow
progression towards a cancer
now this classical folk of grime
colorectal cancer is actually only one
of four subtypes that are nowadays
studied there is a another
characteristic one which is called
microsatellite instable tumor which is
the one you can see on the left then the
next type of colorectal cancer is the
so-called can not canonical one that I
just presented and then there two other
types a metabolic one an amazing final
one and all these all these four types
can actually be be studied in our at the
via culture system
now why is it important to have a good
in vitro method and what can be in vitro
methods are there to study cancer well
of course you cannot study cancer very
well in a patient so you need to use
some methods outside the human body and
traditionally people use cancer cell
lines that are derived from tumor
biopsies but these have have several
issues for example of course they don't
show the heterogeneity within a tumor so
the you don't they tend to grow very
close early and at some point we'll be
representing essentially one cell found
on a tumor they're also genetically very
unstable acquire a lot of mutations due
to the culturing the other system that
people views is transplanting tumor cell
lines or tumor cells from the patient's
into mice a met of course has issues
with because humans and mice are not
alike you need to use immunodeficient
mice and therefore cannot study them how
how the immune system for example
influences tumor growth and yet
similarly to the core colorectal cancer
cell line you do not have the
heterogeneity of the tumor reflected in
in the system and last not least the
system is very low in throughput and
very expensive so the development of
organoids
and I'm showing you in the bottom
essentially our system how we actually
generate these we take a biopsy of the
adult small intestine off of a patient
for example or of a mouse and also the
the colon of course we can isolate the
crypts which contain the stem cells and
we can weaken from there isolate the
stencils and put them in in an extra
cellar matrix which environment and grow
them up into so-called intestine at the
co-organized there are other ways to
generate organize that I will just show
one of them is actually directly taking
the crypts and putting them into the
marchi gel or the beauty and you can
generate the same organoids
and there are two other ways you can
generate organoids but these are not if
they feel organized because they also
contain the mazing time'll cell
rounding so the rest of my talk will be
concentrating only on the self on the
organized culture as I showed you the
beginning which we call it a fear
organize now if you take a normal
intestinal stem cell LG fi+ you can see
now on the screen how this actually
develops over time and culture so you
see from a single cell over about two
weeks the whole cell is SATA fighting
will grow will generate more and more
cells and will essentially generate an
empathy organoid as we have done in
culture so this is actually what happens
there it's a very defined culture medium
as well that we have associated with it
so what are the characteristics of these
organized they are three-dimensional and
as I said they can be established from a
single adult stem cells and they require
certain niche factors that are important
such as EGF noggin and I respondent but
they are all epithelia is no mazing kind
of no no cells no fiberglass in there
and and they date in the beginning of
course are generated from a stem cell
but as time progresses the culture
progresses these organizers will also
contain the differentiated cell types
found in the in the intestine for
example entra sites and they can be
expanded indefinitely and in contrast to
the other methods i introduced you
earlier they're genetically very stable
and actually only acquire mutations at
the similar rate as you would find in
the human body now we thought to use
this if a co-author on culture systems
and use this to actually maintain
colorectal cancer organ earth cells as
well and this is what you can see here
so we essentially take the tumor
resected tissue so usually if part of
the colon has taken out and take a
biopsy from the tumor and take a biopsy
from the from the about 10 to 15
centimeter distant normally the theme
make a single cell preps or isolate the
crypts from the normal colon and then
can put them in to be me and as you can
see on the screen we can generate these
organized as you as I showed you earlier
so this is our starting point for the
continuing studies now you could you
could ask how can we make sure that in
the Torah for example we do not have any
normal tissue left well that's very easy
because actually a large fraction of
these of the tumors have mutations in
the wind' pathway almost 100% so they
have actually a chronically activated
wind pathway and therefore do not
require a condition medium that we use
to maintain the normal colon openers
that is a wind condition medium so
essentially by growing the correct
cancer organoids in the absence of this
wind condition medium we can ensure that
we only grow human tissue and in the
normal tissue we usually can actually
identify by sequencing whether it's
normal or not and usually the growth
will tell you as well whether it's
meditation
now we can use these colorectal cancer
organoids and the adjacent normal tissue
to generate a bio bankers by essentially
taking a lot of biopsies from patients
that gave informed consent and we have
created a foundation that actually takes
care of i banking this and then you can
see on the screen several other tissues
and associative cancers for which we
have established living cancer organized
biobank and what do we do with this we
can use these organoids and these bio
banks as an experimental tool or we can
have basic biological questions related
to stem cell biology infectious diseases
or cancer and indeed we can also use
these to test track efficiency do
genomic analysis can take you to what
drug might be used so for diagnostic
purposes organize can be used as well
and lastly this is something that will
still take some time until it is
possible although proof of principle
experiments have been done already these
bio banks disorganized bio banks can be
used for therapeutic use for example in
the sense of transplanting organized
grown up to organ size of new organ size
or at least to contribute to part of the
organ and we can use them also for gene
correction from planting gene corrected
tissue back into a patient but this is
still something that we need to improve
now I will introduce you to our
colorectal cancer overload biobank that
we have created three years ago which
actually is a biobank of 19 patients and
and they're they're organized grown from
their tumors and we have used this for
in various way to analyze the DNA
sequence so we could identify the Cure
mutations present we studied the
transcriptome of these organized and
then performed drug screens and other
things to see whether we can actually
use the gene expression data to predict
the particular drugs work on the tumor
and as we can always do in comparison to
the normal organized
Corin organoids because we have those
also in culture
now if you don't believe me I will show
you some slides showing actually that
the organizer will grow from me to
magazine
very much reflects the it's a theme in
the original BIOS so you can see some in
attack Ceylon and years in staining that
show that the way the tumor grows has
organoid it's very much alike to what
you see in the patients or the the
histological analysis projector so show
this to a pathologist they really really
recognize the resemblance of the
overnight and resemblance towards the
patient's original tumor what we've done
in addition is we we looked into how
similar the genetic alterations
limitations are we that we find in the
tumor and then in comparison to the
organoids and we could see that the
overlap between the two between the
original biopsy and the overlap is very
very striking it's close to 90% in in
many cases so showing that the organized
really truly reflect what you find in
the in the tomb of the theme and the
patient and of course we also find the
typical mutations that are introduced
you in the beginning a PC on the top
right p53 K Roth a typical mutations
found in colorectal cancer and they are
also present in our overnight biobank
and also in organoids collected or
generated from patients collectively
patient samples collected a bit later
now these are tumor types that I
mentioned in the beginning can be
identified by doing transcriptional
analysis that's what we did also with
the organized and I'm not so sure if you
can see this on the screen but if you
look in the top bar you can see these
orange dots and they actually represent
the organoids that that that we have
generated and that in X passion you can
see they fall into all the four types of
colon cancer so they really really
represent the whole spectrum of
collective sense
now in addition based on for example the
gene expression pattern and the DNA
sequencing we can make predictions where
their particular drug that their target
the particular signaling pathway will
work on patients and you can see on the
top muttering PA is a drug that actually
will act on cells that have still normal
p53 and you can see that there the ic50
of those cells that still have a normal
wild-type p53 it's much much lower than
adults that actually have a mutation in
p53 suggesting that a drug that targets
this pathway will course only work best
in patients that that's the best
wild-type p53 and those that have a
mutation in this pathway will probably
not have us as a very pretty benefit the
same is true for us at AXA map which act
on the EGF a rats pathway you can see
that those that have a well type K rod
still show a good response whereas those
that have a mutated chaos and not
sensitive to this drug anymore so if we
can just generate these organized and
then actually look in that in their gene
expression pattern we might be already
able to predict where their particular
drug used on a patient will actually
work or not
now culture conditions are very critical
and this is what you can see on the next
slide that the normal if the theme is
very much dependent on all these key
niche factors such as wind and ice
fondant EGF p38 norgannon tgf-beta
whereas the tumors are more less
actually able to grow independent of
with an despondent for example but also
other components because they simply
have in patients in the k-rod pathway
therefore they will not require EGF and
other signaling pathways and therefore
we will not require any of the other
drugs
now I will summarize this by playing a
video that will follow
[Music]
organoids our long-term cultures derived
from diseased or healthy tissue of
patients or animals this can be done for
almost all patients and for virtually
all organs and with regard to different
diseases such as hereditary disorders
and cancer both healthy and diseased
tissue is isolated from an organ these
small tissue fragments are placed in
culture the isolated stem cells then
grow into organoids these organoids
are very similar to real organs and form
a reliable testing environment for
medicines against all kinds of diseases
[Music]
using DNA sequencing errors in the
genetic code can be detected we can also
screen multiple combinations of
medicines selectively and reliably on a
large scale organoid technology is a
powerful method which can be used to
design and test patient specific
medicines
okay the last part of my presentation I
will introduce you to ways that we have
developed to actually start from normal
: 850 m and generate organize from this
and then introduce mutations that are
relevant for cancer progression and then
see how things change in the overload
and I introduced in the beginning
already these four key mutations that
are found in the classical collector
cancer APC mutations K Roth p53 and
smart 4 we can actually replicate this
by starting from normal tissue and then
see you are happens
we use CRISPR cos 9 for this which is a
genome editing technique that allows us
to directly introduce mutations in
particular genes we can we can generate
so called Skype RNA that actually target
these and then what we use this we
modulated the composition of the medium
that I showed you earlier and thereby
select for only for example orgonites
that can grow in the absence of EGF in
the medium those orgonites that have a K
Roth mutation for example I will give
you an example on this using the
economical wind signaling pathway that
actually requires with ligands to be
active that's something you can see on
the right hand side in the absence of
the wind ligands there is no gene
expression of the target genes found and
therefore the the Titans cannot be
expressed proliferation is inhibited in
those cells that do not have wind living
up to their receptors in APC newts and
organoids though this father is
chronically active essentially the wind
limit is not required for gene
expression so what you see on the left
is actually present so the wind ligand
is not there but actually in terms of
gene expression the right hand side is
the case of the the the beta catenin and
modulator cannot actually can actually
bind to the target genes and express the
and therefore stimulated proliferation
essentially what we do is we take a
while to overnight growth and add guide
RNAs targeting the APC gene
and then we can wait a couple of days
and then we remove the wind condition
medium and the I respondent condition
meaning which is also required to
stimulate the with pathway and then
after about two weeks we can pick
clothes that grew in the absence of
these four components and then sequence
them and verify this and this is
actually what I show you in the next
slide so you can see that actually these
organize and have frameshift mutations
so you can see this is how it looks in
the top top left of the organized panel
you see a normal organized growing in
the complete
in the complete medium and all the other
five boxes show you organize that grow
in the absence of wind and are spawned
on and you can see only those that
actually mutant so the bottom four
pictures show you organize that grow and
then the one that has gotten up get
guide RNA for growth best we can confirm
that these and this is a representation
of the mutation found in using guide RNA
fold there our friendship mutations
which essentially inactivate a PC and
and allow the pathway to Recology
active and we assess if using qPCR for X
and 2 which is a targeting of this
pathway and you can see that even in the
absence of wind and I spawned in
conditioned media this targeting is
still expressed very nicely actually at
higher levels then with it really nicely
showing that we have introduced these
mutation and now we can use this for all
other mutations found and this is what I
show you here is a bizzy's life so a PC
knockout organ also generated k-rod
activating organized they wouldn't they
don't require each yet then in addition
organized that actually had mutations in
APC and p53 they were selected by the
addition of Madeline and and all the
other combinations essentially
regenerated organoids that contained up
to four oncogenic mutations and and then
we could study them and what we can see
is actually when we transplant these
organoids
we can see that the classical music
organized that have mutations in in APC
in p53 in chaos and smash board are the
ones that actually generate a carcinoma
when injected into mice so therefore
very nicely replicating what you will
see in patients we can also see that
those organized that have all four
mutations are chromosomally in stable
and actually are also really really
perturbed and and generate an allergy
what we did in addition we transplanted
these actually into into the intestinal
region and then studied whether they can
generate and metastasis and this is what
we could and also grow and we could
assess that those actually that have
these four mutations present that are
very much alike a colorectal cancer grow
very very fast significantly faster than
all other mutations and also in the next
slide you can see the ones that have
these four mutations are the ones that
are actually able to metastasize so we
can actually really nicely replicate
what you would see in a patient and by
genetically editing normal organoids so
starting from normal 15 we can really
replicate what happens in a tumor in in
in a patient and a step-by-step and we
can see that only those that have all
four critical mutations are actually
able to metastasize and there's a lot
very low number of those that have much
for wild types of the step before the
carcinoma that are also able to
metastasize possibly and actually in
this case a vision at a species actually
was that contained
later on as you found out imitation in
some at four so essentially there was a
crotch report mutant orgonite something
else we can also do of course we can
also generate gene knockouts in in the
DNA repair complex to replicate at
organized that I like microsatellites
the stable tumors and and we can see
that those uses that have any mutation
in the Naha one which appears very
critical DNA repair gene starts
accumulate a lot of mutations and we can
actually see that based on the organ or
to generate we see very very similar
mutations also in patient samples so
essentially we can replicate the
mutations that you would find in a
patient that has these microsatellite
and stable a cells and we can we can
find the same mutations by just
artificially introducing expectations
and we can therefore
study for two months
so in summary what we can generate is we
can generate apathy of organize from
normal human colon and colorectal cancer
tissue from this we can generate bio
banks that we can use for drug screens
and other things
and we can also genome edit these
organized cultures to study
tumor progression as well as study the
origin augmentation of signatures found
in colorectal cancer and other other
tumors
I would like to thank the head of the
life and flavors and also several other
people that are still in the lab or have
left the lab that have significantly
contributed to the work and I would like
to thank all our collaborators in the
reflect Institute in house in the
University Medical Center as a
Netherlands Cancer Institute as well as
the Wellcome Trust Sanger Institute and
I would like to also thank all the
funding agencies that make this work
possible
last not least thank you for your
attention and I'm looking forward to
your questions
you
you
thank you doctor crush bar for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just type
them into the ask a question box and
click on the send button well answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation questions we
did not have time for today will be
answered by dr. Kirsch Mar via email
following the presentation so let's get
started our first question is what is
the success rate of establishing these
organoids from patients
yeah the success rate is actually in the
case of colorectal cancer pretty high
it's it's 90 95 percent of the samples
we receive actually we can generate over
notes from so it's it's in the case of
this particular tumor type very very
good actually
our next question is can single-cell
mRNA sequencing be performed from the
collect colorectal cancer organoids yes
that that works very well so we have
we've started of course with with
overnights from the mouth small
intestine and and it it gives very very
good results and the same is actually
also true for human normal colon
organoids you can get very very good
single cell transcriptome data and
actually for for cultured colorectal
cancer organized that is the same
for how long can the colorectal cancer
organoids be maintained in culture this
is a very good point actually so we have
we have some of these in culture for two
years already and they seem to be still
going fine and still be very very
primary like in the way they behave so
yes so in principle it can be a very
very long time much longer than you can
usually do with for example colorectal
cancer cell lines that they tend to kind
of behave more like an immortalized cell
line
are you primarily focused on the
epithelial organoids or do you culture
with them with Messick I'm as well
our system we really specialize on
apatheia organized so we only have the
matzo gel that is supporting the growth
so we don't have an actual cellular
musing camera meesh
but in principle that might be something
that that is interesting to look at but
but for our purposes in particular for
the drug screens we really like to see
how the tumor if a theme itself behaves
and works and and don't really do means
and comes also in for our purposes we do
not do it but I believe in principle it
is probably possible
what is the size of the organized needed
for the transplantation in animal models
so I think there it really is dependent
on on what what organoids
you use and colorectal cancer you
actually implant because I would say
that in some cases you might have issues
with with the maintenance in in the in
the in the transplant in the transplants
or maybe they I don't know they
differentiated way or something like
that and also so stable necessarily but
a particular size I am actually I
actually don't know personally and
because I'm not doing these kind of
presentations but I would say probably
organize kept for about a week should be
should be good it's just a matter more
of the number of organelles that you
transplant
how do you measure the viability
percentage after drug treatment whereas
organoids are variable in size yeah this
is this is indeed a very good point and
that's that's something that's something
that we we cannot we in the in the
beginning had really trouble with and
that is that we now actually filter the
orgonite so that they are maximum about
40 micron micrometer in size and then
and then then really look at that to
make sure that that we do that what we
actually do to check for viability
specifically is and we use an ATP based
assay which essentially gives you an
indication of the overall growth and
then you need to of course have controls
that have about the same growth
efficiency possible use the same organ
online as control to actually adjust for
for the differences in size and growth
but we usually tend to use organizers
that are rather small because they can
grow much larger than 40 micrometer
actually
morphology and growth rate when
comparing normal organoid and crc
samples we did not detect very obvious a
very obvious difference do you think
that in vitro culture system cannot
translate the in vivo settings in some
cases due to growth factors we add
so I think that so that the normal
organized that you saw in the
presentation were actually cultured in
medium that is more expansion medium
where we essentially maintain the the
LGA v stem cells that we've built the
the smaller the small intestinal order
of the colonic if you see so so if you
were to change some components in that
medium you would actually get them to
differentiate and they would look much
much different to the to the correct
cancer organized I have to say though
that the that the colorectal cancer
organize themselves tend to look really
really different depending on what type
of organization have and the ones that
you saw in the in the presentation where
actually those classical photogram
colorectal cancers which have mutations
in in for example the wind pathway and
they tend to be very cystic so you can
also have other types them using chiral
one in particular or actually also the
microsatellite and stable one where the
organized of the tumors actually very
dense and you don't have this hollow
cysts like structure and therefore you
can really make a difference between the
normal and the tumor and we just have a
look I think the critical point is that
also in vivo actually there is a there's
a kind of natural gradient of these
growth factors Aware's and tissue
culture where we grow the organiz
the kite it so there will be something
if in my engineers would would enable
that that they that somehow you could
actually have a gradient of these growth
factors implied in your culture system
you might actually have a really clear
differences between the tumor and the
normal because the tumor organoids are
pretty much actually mmm independent of
these growth factors and probably could
also grow in the absence of them
our next question is how difficult will
it be to derive organoids
from other tumors without clear
indication of the existence of cancer
stem cells
so I hope that that that the question
means other tumor types that are not
from the colon so in most cases the
problem is really to find the best media
composition or two for the organizer to
grow so so you will have to start
probably from normally two Thiam maybe
and try to get that to grow and usually
the the tumor will grow in that
condition too but of course you will
have to be sure that you somehow can
select for the tumor either by studying
modifications are in this tumor I
mentioned for example that you can use
Nuttall in in case there is is p53
mutant and you this way you can select
for self that still have a wild-type p53
and would die in the presence of Knutson
and then only the tumor that is p53
would grow out so it depends it depends
it is generally it should be possible if
you really work out the right culture
conditions cancer stem cells is another
thing because I think there is still a
big debate where the cancer stem cells
as such actually existed for the colon I
can tell you that in most cases when we
do when we passage these organize we
actually trypsin eyes them into single
cells and actually it's maybe not 100
percent outgrowth but we get a very very
good outgrowth efficiency 90 percent 95
percent which which doesn't really make
sense if you think that there are really
dedicated stem cells in this tumor if
all of the cells that you have in the
tumor seems to be growing out of
virtually all cells I should probably
caution so that's that's a different
question I think
is there a difference for the percentage
of success in organoids culture from
cancer patient samples and healthy
patient samples
so we don't get actually organized
samples from healthy patients so of
course because what we actually in our
case at least we we get we get the the
colon if the theme from from a section
so actually that the certain bits of the
colon are really resected out and from
there we can take the normal to theme
the only way you could have access to
normal if you feel organized from really
a healthy patient is probably after a
colonoscopy where they take a biopsy but
but usually that's not done if there is
no evidence for any any let's say
indication of a disease because of
course you don't want to injure in
normal healthy clearly associated clear
perfume so all the samples we have from
human are actually from disease from
cancer patients
have you already established a bio bank
and are any drug industries interested
in cancer drug testing with organoids is
it more efficient than cell culture yeah
we have established a biobank and
actually I mentioned this half biobank
in the presentation
they actually have established I think
more than a hundred colorectal cancer
organoid lines now so that's already
been done and indeed we have
collaborations with the drug industry
teamed up with several companies big
companies and also smaller companies and
and use and they use the kind of these
bio banks so actually also companies can
approach the hub biobank and ask for two
by organoid lines for their research and
and that's going very well
it is indeed more efficient than let's
say regular cell culture because the
colorectal cancer organoid lines really
are reflecting heterogeneity of the
tumor they don't tend to be immortalized
so they stay rather primary where's the
cell culture cell lines that you use the
classical colorectal cancer cell and
they tend to be not behaving as as they
were when they were primary so I would
say it is pretty good but what I have to
caution is that core like organ or
cultures in general is a very very
laborious and very money intense work so
so it would be if you compare that it
really depends on your questions that
you're addressing it might still be
better for you to use cell lines because
it's very very you need to put a lot of
effort into this
if you pass it CRC organoids via
single-celled Association are you not
worried to lose tumor heterogeneity and
to select for high growth cells so this
is this is a very good question that's
that is surely possible although we have
actually done single cell sequencing
from classical colorectal cancer
organoids and they tend to be not so had
to genius as you would think I think
that the heterogeneity between patients
is much bigger there are there are other
subtypes for example I guess the
microcephaly and stable ones which Mitch
and seem to be much more diverse in
their in limitation status and in
limitations that they acquire and that
could be a problem but with the
classical photogram colorectal cancer
organized I would not be so worried but
of course you can you can actually
generate clonal cultures and then study
as many clones as you like to right from
the two men and see how different they
actually are but that's of course a
problem that is possible but that
problem is even worse when you study
just regular cell culture to DC lines
what are the special characteristics of
the mat-su gal you use in your organized
is it commercially available so matcha
gel is is generated by a company
actually and that them several companies
that produce something like matcha gel
also a something called basement member
and extract Niemi is actually very
similar with that what we mostly use
actually nowadays the special thing
about this is that this is actually
isolated from sarcoma are grown on mice
and it contains extracellular matrix on
this from this sac Roma from this tumor
and a stroma and actually seller matrix
proteins and that that really support
the organ or growth and that's really
critical so that the cells are in a 3d
environment not in a 2d environment and
it seems to be supporting the growth
very very well so that's a special thing
about it essentially it's xlm Atrix do
you have experience with transplanting
these organoids in zebrafish I showed
answer no and and for us really it's
it's we have not worked with ever fish
cells at all in that sense that we try
to generate organize from them and also
of course have not transplanted them
into into the zebrafish so we only
transplant into into my steps the only
experiments in vivo experimental system
we actually use
do you have bio banks of prostate
organize or only colorectal
I believe the the biobank does have also
generated those from from prostate
organize let me just go back to the
slide so we can check together
yes it's listed it's listed there so it
is actually one of the tumor types where
we do have biobank organoids
at what ratio can the colorectal cancer
organize be split they grow really
really well and in most cases you can
split them one in six up to one and 12
so you can generate a lot of cells in a
rather short time
all right our next question is how often
do the colorectal cancer organize have
to be passage or split
while the packaging is really dependent
on on your question if you want to
propagate the organize and keep them
really nicely in culture then this has
to be done about once a week
you
thank you dr. crash Mar do you have any
final comments for our audience yeah I
would like to thank all of you for for
listening in and if you have any
questions you can you can always get in
touch with us the who liked Institute
and also get in touch for example with
the biobank the hub biobank and see if
there are any ways you can have access
to these organized lines but overall
thank you very much for this opportunity
and for your attention thank you I would
like to once again thank dr. Kai crash
Mart for his presentation I would also
like to thank laborat and thermo Fisher
Scientific for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I would like to remind everyone that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through August of 2018
you will receive an email from laberd's
alerting you when this webcast is
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye